l'administration de joe biden a esquissé
ce lundi ce qu'elle souhaite instaurer
en termes de relations commerciales avec
la chine par la voix de la représentante
américaine du commerce catherine taille
l'administration de la maison blanche
fait part de son intention de ne pas
enflammer les tensions commerciales mais
au contraire d'avoir des discussions
franches avec les autorités chinoises il
y a notamment la question centrale est
piteuse défaite 3-2 douane punitifs
370 milliards de dollars de taxes
douanières annuelles sur les produits
chinois sont actuellement en vigueur des
taxes maintenu par l'administration de
joe biden mais qui pourrait à l'avenir
constituer un levier dans les
négociations que souhaite amorcer
washington avec pékin washington veut en
fait plus généralement s'attaquer à ce
qu'il présente comme des problèmes
structurels de l'économie chinoise
d'abord il ya la question des
subventions massives dont bénéficient
les entreprises d'état en chine et puis
les accusations aussi de la part de
washington de vol de la propriété
intellectuelle et plus généralement le
déséquilibre commercial défavorable powa
shing tonnes dans ses relations
économiques avec la chine les etats unis
qui affirme aussi pouvoir se tourner
vers d'autres partenaires et d'ailleurs
ils veulent convaincre les alliés
européens de les suivre sur cette
stratégie de fermeté à l'égard de pékin
mais il y a des divergences importantes
parce qu'on sait qu'au sein de l'union
européenne certains pays comme
l'allemagne par exemple ont des
relations commerciales très forte avec
la chine et ne veulent certainement pas
faire preuve de plus de fermeté comme le
voudrait pourtant washington on peut
dire aussi que l'administration de joe
biden finalement s'inscrit dans la
lignée de la politique de donald trump
sur ce dossier des relations
commerciales avec pékin même si à
catherine taille affirme qu'il y à des
imperfections dans l'accord signé en
2020 par l'ancien président des états
unis elle dit vouloir avoir une approche
pragmatique avec la chine et c'est donc
pour toutes ces raisons qu'elle va
assister à des négociations ces
prochains jours à paris au sein de l'
ocde il faut dire enfin que washington
est pressé par des groupes d'affaires
ici aux etats-unis qui sont fortement
impactés par ces frais de douane
actuellement en vigueur